DAN: I met Fred
a couple of years
ago, at the SF Green Festival.
Amid the organic food and
soaps and different ways
of using plastic, Fred
had something different,
something which could
improve the lives of millions
of poor people around the world.
And I wanted to let Fred share
that idea with you today.
Fred Colgan is the co-founder
of InStove, a nonprofit which
is designing, building, and
distributing large, highly
efficient cook stoves
in developing countries.
He's joined by Assitan
Sylla Traore, Africa project
coordinator at InStove.
She is a Fulbright
scholar from Mali,
with 18 years of
experience working
with senior political and
diplomatic leaders in Mali.
Please join me in
welcoming Fred and Assitan.
FRED COLGAN: Thanks, Dan.
Well, hi.
I'm Fred Colgan.
I'm the executive director
and co-founder of InStove.
Our full name is
Institutional Stove Solutions.
We're a 501(c)3
non-profit organization,
and the manufacturer of clean
and efficient cook stoves
and allied technologies
for the developing world.
Now, when you think
of clean cook stoves,
you may think of some gleaming
new electric or gas range.
And when you think of
institutional kitchens,
you may think of the
fantastic workplaces
you see on celebrity
chef programs.
But the reality in
the developing world
is more like this.
Chances are, your
last meal wasn't
prepared over an open fire.
But for about one out of
three people on Earth, it was.
The cost of this is
staggering, globally.
It leads to deforestation,
climate change, illness,
gender-based violence,
and even death.
And the social costs
fall especially
hard on the shoulders of
women and young girls,
who do the cooking
and fuel gathering.
2.7 billion people use
open fires to cook.
Today, in sub-Saharan Africa,
which is our principle market,
over 657 million people
use biomass fuels--
like wood, charcoal, or
dung-- as a primary source
of household energy.
While much of the planet is
moving away from this model,
in Africa, there are
multiple barriers-- political
instability, corruption,
regional conflicts,
all preventing many
from gaining access
to electricity or
to modern fuels.
The reality is that the
infrastructure simply
is not enough to deliver
electricity and modern fuels.
It's not growing fast
enough to meet demands,
either current or projected.
Every few years, the
International Energy Agency
does an assessment of
energy use worldwide.
They collect their
findings and analyses
in a report called "The
World Energy Outlook."
I want to share one finding of
the IEA in their 2011 report.
"While Africa's share
of the global population
increases from 15% in 2009
to 20% percent in 2035,
its share of global
energy demand
declines fractionally to 5.4%
over the same time frame.
Furthermore, 1/3 of the total
energy demand in Africa by 2035
takes the form of
traditional biomass use."
In that same report,
the IEA projects
that the number of people
in sub-Saharan Africa
who will use biomass as
their primary source of fuel
will be over 900
million people in 2035.
That means, in
Africa, two decades
from now, the number of
people burning wood to cook
will have grown by almost 50%.
The environmental damage
from this is two-fold.
First, the open-fire
cooking produces a long list
of noxious chemicals,
like benzene, and methane,
and toluene.
But the black carbon
and particulate matter
is especially impactful
on climate change.
It's estimated that open-fire
cooking in the world
produces more climate
change emissions
than the one billion
cars on the planet.
Second, the unsustainable
harvesting of firewood
destroys the very
forests that help
to mitigate climate change.
On average, throughout
sub-Saharan Africa,
the level of deforestation
is between 3% to 4%
of existing forest each year.
And in some regions,
like in northern Nigeria,
that deforestation rate
climbs to over 11% per year.
Deforestation brings
with it a cascade
of environmental
and social problems
that include acceleration
of desertification.
And the loss of watersheds,
the loss of habitat.
And the loss of livelihoods the
depend on forest ecosystems.
But the costs of
open-fire cooking
have a human dimension as well.
The most recent global
burden of disease study,
published he asked last
year in "The Lancet,"
found that 4.3 million people
die each year from illnesses
caused by exposure to
indoor air pollution.
By way of comparison,
more people
die each year from cook smoke
than from HIV, AIDS, malaria,
and tuberculosis combined.
And this statistic does
not include those who die
or become disfigured by burns
sustained while cooking.
This statistic does not include
the eye diseases-- including
cataracts and macular
degeneration-- that
come from exposure to
indoor air pollution, which
often lead to blindness.
And this statistic
does not include
the gender-based
violence suffered
by women and young girls
who cook outdoors, and trek
long distances-- often through
dangerous territory-- in search
of firewood together.
These women and
girls must continue
to go out because
gathering firewood is not
only necessary for
their family's survival.
It's often the only
income-generating activity
available to them,
especially in refugee camps
and internally
displaced persons camps.
When I went to Nyala
in Darfur in 2011,
I was fortunate enough to
work with a large group
of African women who were cooks
in the schools in the camp.
And after I gave a
demonstration at one camp,
a focus group of cooks
told me that they
have to travel outside the
camp to gather firewood.
And one out of every
three times they go out,
they're sexually assaulted.
These problems are enormous.
But at their root is a
solvable engineering problem.
How do you design
a stove to make
biomass cooking
more efficient, one
that uses minimal
amounts of fuel,
while producing minimal
amounts of emissions,
and being safe for users?
In 2005, I wasn't
aware of most of this,
though I had some
developing world experience.
I was 60 years old.
And my wife and
I moved to Oregon
to retire to a little place
on the bank of the Willamette
River in Oregon.
I had planned to re-read
my science fiction
library in my retirement years.
But that plan
wasn't meant to be.
The property we bought
had an abandoned
slaughterhouse and
meat-packing plant on it.
So I restored this building.
And our first tenant was
Aprovecho Research Center.
This is a nonprofit
research group
that's been working for 30 years
on the design and development
of clean-biomass cook stoves,
including the iconic rocket
stove.
And almost immediately at
Aprovecho, I met Damon Ogle.
Damon was a retired
mechanical engineer
who had spent many years with a
successful independent business
with portable
rock-crushing mills,
providing rock crushing to
government and mining clients
throughout the Western US.
Damon took an early retirement.
And he began looking for
ways to put his engineering
experience to humanitarian use.
Eventually, his interest in
water and sanitation systems
in the developing world
led him to Aprovecho,
who were
world-recognized leaders
in appropriate technology,
and within driving distance
for Damon.
He joined Aprovecho
as a volunteer.
And he began devoting the
second half of his life
to using his engineering talents
to give back to humanity.
After spending several years
of designing household stoves
and implementing stove projects
throughout the developing
world, Damon began
focusing on building larger
institutional rocket
stoves in places
like refugee camps, and
schools, and hospitals,
and rural clinics.
Households stoves are simply
not sufficient to meet the need.
These are institutions where
large quantities of food
are prepared quickly.
This kind of cooking presents
different design challenges.
But because of the
high level of fuel use
and the high level of
resulting emissions,
Damon saw that when
you placed one improved
institutional stove, the
impact is an order of magnitude
higher than placing
a household stove.
At Aprovecho, Damon learned
about the ten rocket stove
principles from their creator,
and our friend, Doctor Larry
Winiarski.
These ten principles
are as follows.
First, insulate around the fire
with a low-mass, heat-resistant
material.
The objective of this is to
create a refractive combustion
chamber.
The goal is not to heat the
stove, but to heat the pot.
Number two, use an insulated,
upright, internal chimney
immediately above the fire, to
promote mixing of the gases--
the pyrolated gases-- and
to complete the combustion.
Number three, design
a stove to heat
and burn only the
tips of the sticks
as they enter the
combustion chamber.
This is analogous to avoiding
burning too lean or too rich
in a gasoline engine.
Number five, design the stove
to maintain high-air velocity
through the system.
And number five, do not
allow too much or too little
air to enter the
combustion chamber.
Strive to have a stoichiometric,
or a chemically ideal,
combustion.
This can best be achieved
by not jamming the fuel
slot with wood.
Too much fuel blocks air flow.
And it causes
incomplete combustion.
And it produces smoke.
Number six, maintain
constant cross-sectional area
throughout the stove to
eliminate bottlenecks.
And number seven,
elevate the fuel.
And distribute air
flow around the fuel.
The stove works best
when the fuel added
is separated by a shelf
that allows this air flow.
Number eight, use a grate under
the stove, under the fuel,
so that the air flows
through the coals.
Traditional stoves--
open fires that
have fuel resting on
the ground-- experience
difficulty achieving the
correct mix of air and fuel.
Number nine, insulate
the heat-flow path
to and around the
cooking surfaces.
As you can see, in this and in
most household rocket stoves,
this is only partially achieved.
The heat-flow path to
the pot is insulated,
but not beyond the bottom
of the cooking surface.
And finally, number
ten, optimize
the gaps around the
cooking surfaces
to maximize heat transfer
without slowing down the draft.
The supports that
elevate the pot
above the stove in this
kind of rocket stove
create the most critical
gap, where the heat transfer
is reduced if the
gap is too small.
If it's too large,
and a choke point
is created if the
gap is too small.
And it makes a smoky fire.
Now, Damon took these
principles and applied them
to designing an
institutional cook stove.
And what he ended up with was
a stove that looks like this.
Now, this stove's
been designed to best
run on small amounts
of small wood--
little sticks that can
be sustainably harvested.
In contrast, open-fire
cooking for institutions
tends to require large
amounts of large wood
to generate enough heat energy
for the large pots they use.
Most of this energy is wasted.
A really efficient
three-stone fire
is, at best, only about
15% thermally efficient.
That means 85% of the heat
energy never reaches the pot.
Our stove, from the moment
heat energy is generated,
forces heated air to flow
up through the stove,
following a path that
provides maximum opportunity
for heat exchange with
the cooking surfaces
to the bottom of the pot, and
then along its sides as well.
Additional heat is retained
in the stove in this chamber
by the metal skirt,
or the pot surround.
As gases descend into
another insulated space,
we improve efficiency
with retained heat.
Then those gases exit the stove
through the external chimney.
This design creates
an optimum draft,
which pulls the heat
at a constant velocity
through the system.
With this stove, we have
reached 50% thermal efficiency.
By way of contrast, the average
internal combustion engine
is about 20% percent efficient.
And the Prius we drove down here
today is about 40% efficient.
With this stove, we get
more work out of wood
than modern combustion
engines get out of gasoline.
In 2007, when Damon
first began designing
what he was calling
a barrel stove,
Dr. Winiarski, the
father of rocket stoves,
was also working at Aprovecho.
And Larry had a
drawing of a design
for an institutional stove that
didn't have a metal combustion
chamber.
At the time, the
conventional wisdom
was, you can't use metal to
build rocket stove combustion
chambers.
But Damon was stubborn,
as engineers who are right
sometimes can be.
And he said, everyone thought
ceramic was the way to go.
But my experiments keep showing
that the best results came out
of a metal combustion chamber.
So Damon designed his
metal combustion chamber,
and wanted to build and
test his barrel stoves
in the field, where the
experiment would do some good.
So he soon found a place
that needed some stoves.
At the time, our
friend Ken Goyer
had just started Aid Africa, a
nonprofit in northern Uganda,
where the Lord's Resistance
Army, led by Joseph Kony,
was terrorizing the region.
Damon traveled there in 2007.
And he brought with him
through customs a dozen
different combustion
chambers, each
made from different
high-temperature alloys not
available in African markets.
And Damon trained a
team of local workers
to build this first 12 prototype
stoves using local pots,
and local parts.
But used the combustion
chambers that he
had brought to make a variety
of field-testing prototypes.
He placed the stoves in
several institutions,
including the Laroo School
for War-Affected Children.
And a year later, he
came back to measure
how the different combustion
chambers had worked, and held
up when put through
rigorous daily use.
When he returned to
Oregon after this,
to design the first
60-liter stoves,
that's when I met up with him.
Now, Damon and I hit
it off pretty quick,
and realized we shared
a passion to serve,
and a vision of realistic
approaches to the development
and the proliferation
of technology
to serve the world's
poorest people.
We continue our
close collaboration.
And Damon today still directs
our research and development
department.
And I head up the day-to-day
operations of our organization.
In 2008 and 2009, we continued
testing and tinkering
and improving Damon's model.
And our first
break came in 2010,
when the German international
cooperation and aid
agency called GIZ
asked us to do a pilot
project with 60-liter stoves
in a girls' school in Bita,
in northern Nigeria.
The Bita Girls Secondary
School is an amazing place,
a school with 1,600
female students, divided
between Muslim and
Christians, where
there are no
religious conflicts.
And I traveled there in 2010,
and installed three stoves,
which reduced the school's
fuel costs by 75%.
The stoves were so
efficient that they
paid for the installation
in seven months.
Four years later,
these three stoves
are still providing the
food for the 1,600 students.
And the head cook,
Hajia Ishmael,
the woman who brought
her infant son with her
to work on her back every
day, shared this with me.
"With the new stoves,
my eyes don't water.
My chest doesn't hurt.
My back doesn't ache.
And the baby on my back
has stopped crying."
This project was so successful,
we soon had an order in hand
from a UN agency for
200 stoves for Darfur.
Since 2010, we've placed over
1,000 stoves in 25 countries,
including 15 countries
in sub-Saharan Africa.
Damon and I agreed
early on that bringing
not just the technology,
but the production of stoves
to a country-- just like
he had done in Uganda--
was the ultimate goal.
So we developed a
stove production method
to be replicable,
and created a method
we call Stove Factory in a Box.
Now, in this model, we put
all the materials and tools
necessary to build our stoves
into a shipping container.
We ship this container
to an in-country partner.
And then, following the
arrival of the container,
we send a team of
InStove's stove builders
to teach local workers
how to replicate
our manufacturing process.
What we found in our research
and development of the stove
was that the difference
of the few millimeters
could cost 15% or 20%
percent in efficiency.
Our stoves require
precision manufacturing.
So we designed our
system to force precision
through the use of custom jigs
and very exacting standards.
Our factory runs
on minimal energy,
and can easily be powered
by the few tasks that
require electricity
with a small generator.
By transferring our
tools and know-how,
we can train in-country
workers to build stoves
to our precise
one-millimeter tolerances.
And with Stove
Factory in a Box, we
can bring production
anywhere in the world.
Our goal for each country
where we are needed
is to begin with
small pilot projects,
and then bring a larger number
of stoves for market testing.
And then, if there's
sufficient demand,
we explore partnerships
and pursue funding
to open a factory in-country.
By opening these
local factories,
we create living-wage jobs.
We increase local
economic independence.
And we make our stove
initiative truly sustainable.
By now, you may be
wondering, well,
how good are our stoves, really?
From the beginning,
and for seven years,
we've continued to improve our
design, testing it in the lab
and in the field.
And now, our stoves
are independently
verified by third-party
testing labs
and by hundreds of
users in the field
to consistently accomplish
the following results.
They reduce carbon monoxide and
particulate matter emissions
by 90%.
They cut fuel use by 75%-90%.
And they reduce cooking
time by 50% or more.
The International
Standards Organization
has an International
Workshop Agreement, or IWA,
that's measuring clean cook
stoves in 11 categories,
or indicators, that are ranked
on a scale from one to four,
with four being the
highest ranking.
In nine out of
these 11 indicators,
our stoves are ranked four.
These indicators primarily
measure emissions-- including
carbon monoxide and
particulate matter-- produced
at both high and low powers.
In the world of
stoves, high power
means the power you need to
bring a pot of food to a boil,
or a pot of water to
a boil in the lab.
And low power means
the amount you
need to keep it
simmering as you cook.
In our stove, the temperatures
within the combustion chamber
reach up to 1,150
degrees Celsius.
That's over 2,000
degrees Fahrenheit.
And our stove is burning so
hot that it literally burns up
the smoke.
But how does this
compare to other stoves?
This chart, completed
by researchers
across the bay at the
Berkeley Air Monitoring Group,
compare particular matter
and carbon monoxide produced
at high power in
different kinds of stoves,
including charcoal
stoves and pellet
stoves, fan-driven stoves that
require electricity, chimney
stoves, and griddle stoves, and,
finally, liquid or gas stoves.
And our institutional
rocket stove tests here.
This puts our stove
two categories
above household rocket stoves.
And it puts it nearly on a level
as clean burning as liquid fuel
or gas stoves.
The only way to
improve our performance
would be to change the fuel.
And until natural gas
or LPG grows on trees,
it probably isn't a
viable alternative.
As to cost
effectiveness, our stoves
are so efficient
that in fuel savings,
they pay for themselves, in
most cases, in just over a year
of use.
Here, you can see
our stove being
used alongside some really
rudimentary improved stoves
in Senegal.
When we set up our
stove to cook here,
we couldn't find any
small wood prepared,
because they use large wood to
heat their large pots of food.
So we had to find--
the smallest stick
we could find was this one you
see jammed into the fuel slot.
Our stoves run best on
small amounts of small wood
that can be
sustainably harvested
without destroying whole trees.
But our stoves do
more than cook.
Institutional stoves
produce much more firepower
than other stoves.
And this energy can be harnessed
for additional applications.
Our 100-liter stove works with a
gravity-fed, flow-through water
pasteurizer of our own design.
And this pasteurizer
can produce over
200 gallons of potable
water per hour,
using just a pencil's
weight of wood--
about five grams for
each liter produced.
We field-tested this
pasteurizer in the Zambia
in October of 2013.
And in the field,
just as in the lab,
the pasteurizer eliminates
100% of water-borne pathogens.
With the support of
the Geisse Foundation,
we're now in the research phase
of creating a high-flow sand
filter that will allow us to
address the issue of turbidity,
of particulate
matter in the water.
With this upstream
filter, we'll be
able to filter out
solids, and make
water look as clean and
safe as it really is.
We're exploring partnerships
to implement this technology
as part of rural
micro utilities that
can provide clean water
and sanitation and hygiene
trainings.
And we're looking
at this pasteurizer
as the basis of
a micro business,
providing clean water.
Our 60-liter stove
is also paired
with an autoclave that can
sterilize medical equipment,
making use of supplies
like bandages, dressings,
and scalpels.
It's OK, Assitan.
Yeah, you want to do that?
OK.
Bandages, dressings,
scalpels, needles
can be safe for reuse or
for hygienic disposal,
in accordance with
international medical standards.
This ensemble is already saving
lives in Kenya, and Chad,
and Zambia, and the Democratic
Republic of the Congo.
Thank you.
And we just completed a
pilot project in Kathmandu
that will introduce our
autoclave to rural clinics
across Nepal and help
remote centers there arrive
at international standards in
their waste-disposal practices.
This pilot project also
represents our first entry
into Asian markets.
Because all of our
technologies have
been designed to
work off the grid,
they're ideal for use in
settings where electricity
and modern fuels are scarce,
or unavailable-- places
like rural hospitals and
clinics, or refugee camps,
or in disaster-relief
situations.
We have a long list
of R&D projects,
intending to use the stove
for additional applications.
On our list are a bread oven,
a water pump, a refrigeration
system, and a
cell-phone charging
station, all powered
by the InStove.
We're a nonprofit organization.
And we raise funds from
philanthropic donors,
and sell stoves to
support our mission.
With the importance of
the problems we solve,
and the effectiveness
with which we do it,
it might at first
seem hard to believe
that funding and clients
are difficult to both find
and maintain.
But the markets for stoves
face many challenges, not least
of which is the volatility
of funding cycles.
Our strategy for growth is to
build strategic partnerships
with agencies small and
large throughout the world.
Getting life-changing
technology to the world's poor
is why we exist.
Our mission is to improve
health, to enhance safety,
and to reduce harm
to the environment
through the design, the
manufacture, and the delivery
of highly efficient stoves
and allied technologies
to the most vulnerable
populations worldwide.
We joined the larger unified
fight against indoor pollution
as members of the Global
Alliance for Clean Cook Stoves.
It's a public-private
partnership,
led by the United
Nations Foundation.
The Global Alliance
was born in 2010,
when then-Secretary of State
Hillary Clinton and a range
of leading international
public and private figures
launched it, with the ambitious
mission of transforming
the global market
for clean cook stoves
and fuels with a
specific goal of spurring
the adoption of clean cook
stoves and fuels in 100
million households by 2020.
The Global Alliance
is leading the way
in raising consciousness
around this issue.
And I think they said it best.
"While some may think that the
poor cannot afford to adopt
clean cooking technologies, the
opposite is, in fact, the case.
The poor pay heavily
for their lack of access
to clean cook stoves and fuels."
As we grow, our
priorities are to open
strategic foreign
production units
to bring production in-country
to the countries that need
our stoves the most.
To improve our
value-chain management.
To increase our
capacity-- including
creating several
new staff positions.
To hire African
staff, especially
in the area of marketing
and last-mile distribution.
And to expand into new markets.
It's with these last
two priorities in mind
that I'd like to introduce
you to Assitan Sylla
Traore, the newest
member of InStove's team.
Thank you.
ASSITAN SYLLA TRAORE:
[SPEAKING FRENCH]
Hi, everybody.
Thank you all for
being here today.
We really appreciate it.
I'm here today to
put a human face
on the work InStove
does around the world
to protect women
and save the planet.
My name is Assitan.
I'm InStove Africa's
project coordinator.
I come from Mali, West Africa,
from an extended family.
I have nine siblings.
However, my mom cooked
to feed over 20 people.
She raised over 20 children.
I have four children.
And, like my mom, I've
been cooking alone
to feed the family.
Before coming to
the United States,
I went to school in
Russia, and graduated
from Moscow
Linguistic University,
with a master's
degree in linguistics.
I returned back home
to Mali, and worked
for 18 years in
diplomacy and government
and in the nonprofit sector.
I worked as special assistant
to eight ambassadors of Nigeria
to Mali.
I also worked as special
assistant with Mali government
and in the prime
minister office.
I've been always interested
in gender issues,
and intrigued by the disparity
between women and men
in our society.
So this motivated me
to create a nonprofit
called Assa in Mali
to address issues
like girls' education and
women financial independence.
However, after 18
years of experience,
I felt that I needed
to learn more,
and realized that I
needed to learn more,
to address better the issues
women are facing in my country.
I therefore applied for--
and was granted-- a Fulbright
scholarship to study at
the University of Oregon
in gender, environment, and
environmental issues and women
issues.
So I first met InStove
during a stove demonstration
at the University of Oregon.
I immediately saw the
importance of the work
on women, children,
and the planet.
So, when I graduated
in the fall of 2013,
and they offered to hire me
as Africa project coordinator,
I immediately
accepted the offer.
Unlike in the United States and
in most developed countries,
the most common ways of cooking
in most African countries, even
today, is cooking the food
over a three-stone fire,
exactly as you see
in this picture,
and as it's shown here.
All generations
in my family have
cooked the food over
a three-stone fire,
including myself.
One of my cousins
was severely burned
when he was an infant, while my
aunt was holding him on her lap
and stirring food from a pot.
The [INAUDIBLE] pot
accidentally fell on him,
and burned him badly.
So he was disfigured.
And he could no longer use his
left hand as a normal person.
He's an adult now,
married with children.
But he still has to
bear the consequences
of the open-fire cooking method.
Growing up, I've
seen my mom cook
the food over a
three-stone fire.
The walls of our kitchen back
home are all black from smoke.
Traditionally,
being able to stand
smoke while using
a three-stone fire
is a rite of passage
for all girls.
I remember once asking
my elder daughter,
[? Fattouh, ?] to start
fire, because I needed
to fix breakfast for the family.
So she tried for hours.
The fire wouldn't start.
And her eyes were red.
She was coughing.
And our entire kitchen
was filled with smoke.
And she kept telling me,
Mama, I can't start the fire.
And I kept telling her that
she needed to try harder,
because I thought she was just
being lazy, as all teenagers.
So when I came to the
United States years later,
I started taking classes
and learning new things that
challenged the belief I
was told while growing up
that all girls
needed to learn how
to start a fire, no matter what.
I realized that I was
too hard on my daughter.
And I picked up
the phone one day.
I called her to apologize
for being so hard on her.
But I was trying-- I
was simply trying--
to prepare her to
become a better woman,
as I was taught
when I was a child.
So cooking with a
three-stone fire method
has a lot of
consequences on women,
on people, and the environment.
It leads to deforestation,
because the need is increasing,
the demand is increasing.
It also leads to
gender-based violence,
because women have
to walk father
in the bush to collect wood
for the needs of the family.
So open-fire cooking
also contributes
to lots of diseases, like
eyes, lungs, and heart disease.
I have two of my
daughters who have
been diagnosed with
asthma, from smoke.
Open-fire cooking
contributes also to burns,
as was the case with my
little cousin, Mamadou,
when he was an infant.
It's also a big loss
of time for families.
Because it takes hours
to just set the fire.
And because it's not efficient.
Most fire does not go directly
to the pot, because it's open.
And it takes a lot of time.
And women could use
this time to carry out
other income-generating
activities
to support their families.
So today, as an African
woman, and a mom
who has lived all these
things InStove has been trying
to address, I think that
it is unacceptable today,
in this age of
high-technology development,
for women and girls
to continue to suffer,
to expose their lives to
danger, and harm their health,
just because they want
to feed their family.
But it does not have
to be like that.
Because there is an alternative
to the three-stone cooking
fire method.
InStove cook stove is here.
It's safe, very fast,
efficient, because it does not
use a lot of the wood.
And they do not
produce any smoke.
So, in this picture, you can
see the quantity of wood needed
to cook the same
amount of food--
the small one using
an InStove cook stove,
and a big one using a
three-stone, open-fire cooking
method.
So I was curious.
So I tried one day to
experiment by myself
cooking with an InStove, because
I have experience already
cooking with a three-stone
fire back home,
and I really wanted to
cook with an InStove
to see how efficient it was.
And it was so easy,
I thought to myself.
And it was very easy to start.
So as you can see
in this picture,
you also have a relaxed posture.
When you are using a three-stone
fire, you have to all the time
bend down.
And you cannot even use
your nice clothes to cook,
because they will
be dark with smoke.
And after you finish cooking,
your clothes will stink.
You cannot even serve the food
without taking a shower before.
So I was relaxed.
And I could cook with dignity,
even in my nice clothes,
using an InStove--
which is not possible
with a three-stone
cooking fire method.
So it was very fast.
And I could put this stove
anywhere in the house,
without worrying about
my walls being dark,
or smoke being around the house.
So it was a great experience.
And it's a really
efficient stove.
So how can all of us together
address these issues?
So I really believe
in the mission
InStove is doing around the
world to save the environment
and protect women.
Because I have lived
all these issues
InStove is trying to solve.
And I have experience
about all these things
it's trying to address.
So I hope that all
of you here today
will join me to support InStove,
to bring this life-saving stove
to people who need it the
most around the world.
So you can be involved by
trying to learn more about us
on our website, by
typing www.instove.org.
We have a good
volunteer program.
You can volunteer with us
in Cottage Grove, Oregon.
And also, you can help
us with new ideas,
because there is always
room for improvement.
And also, you can
support our mission.
We're a small nonprofit.
And our work is being
made possible by donations
from our supporters.
So on this note, I
would like to thank
you very much for
your attention.
And if you have any
questions, Fred and I
would be happy to
answer your questions.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
AUDIENCE: I was
wondering how much
it costs to install an
InStove, like, generally.
FRED COLGAN: OK, the
pricing is-- this stove,
this 60-liter stove,
costs $950 US.
That's our humanitarian price.
We have a stove nearly twice as
big, which is a 100-liter pot.
And that's $1,300 US.
So we're priced for
institutional cooking.
And where these are
placed, primarily,
are organizations that have some
sense of cost-benefit analysis.
So they can see very
early-- very quickly
that the stove pays for
itself very quickly, just
with fuel costs alone.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: I was
curious, just like,
if you were to do like a
big fundraising effort.
You know, sometimes
for people, it's
better to see, like, oh, you're
buying x amount of stoves--
just try to set fundraising
goals and stuff.
FRED COLGAN: Yeah.
We partner with a lot of NGOs.
So a lot of groups come
to us and say, well, we
want to get two stoves for our
project and the orphanage we
support in Kenya.
So they raise the money
for a couple of stoves.
And bingo, there they are.
And that's how we got to many of
our countries around the world.
ASSITAN SYLLA TRAORE: And
what I would like to add
is that our stoves are designed
for use in institutions,
like school feeding programs,
orphanages, hospitals,
where people cook large
quantities of food
to feed many people at a time.
So they are not
meant for family.
This is the institutional size.
FRED COLGAN: But there are
also commercial applications.
So commercial cooks
could use this stove
and save money and protect
their health at the same time.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Thank you so much.
As I said, I'm from Ivory Coast.
And my childhood had
been similar to yours.
I was lucky enough to
more from the village
at an early age
to go to the city.
So I saved my eyes
a little bit, but.
[LAUGHS] And thank you for
this great innovation, really.
I mean, I know that you think
of bigger institutions, and kind
of bigger cooking.
And I can see it's really
good to be able to do that.
But have you thought also
in terms of family, kind of?
Because in some parts of
Africa nowadays-- I mean,
where there's relative peace,
their bigger concern remains
in terms of feeding their
family in a small kind of--
have you thought of that?
And also, when you go to
African big institutions, what
are the challenges you face?
Have you--
FRED COLGAN: Ok.
Well, OK.
Several questions there.
First, household stoves--
we decided early on
to address this one niche
to build institutional cook
stoves for institutional
situations.
That's about 10% of
all the cooking that
takes place,
particularly in Africa.
Household cooking-- there
are a lot of players
now in the global markets.
The Global Alliance is
promoting the development
of household stoves, primarily.
It's much more complicated
than institutional cooking.
Household stoves need to be
designed for very low prices
to accomplish a lot.
And then they need to
be adopted by women,
whose primary interest
is that the food tastes
like their grandma's
food tasted.
And that's very tricky to
do, to change technologies.
So it's been-- it's
an ongoing challenge
to convince women to change
their cooking habits to adopt
more modern stoves.
And also, to come up with
the money to pay for them.
It's-- at $10 or $15 or $20,
that's a very expensive stove
in African markets.
And it's very hard to
deliver an industrial product
for those kind of prices.
So, like I said, there
are many players.
We're focused on institutions.
And we're going to let
our colleagues address
the household cooking issue.
We may get drawn into
that at some point.
But for the moment, we're
going to stay focused.
The challenges are huge--
logistical challenges.
To get stoves from Oregon
to anywhere in Africa,
there are all kinds of
issues that come up.
Just the raw logistics of
getting shipments into country
through customs,
past corruption,
and into the hands of
users is very challenging.
Finding funding sources,
finding agencies
who can afford
the stoves and can
afford to participate in
development is very tricky.
There are a host of
problems-- host of challenges,
I would say.
We're still overcoming them.
We're learning to overcome them.
We have a container of stoves
arriving this week in Kampala,
in Uganda, for a
wider distribution.
So that's the second tier
of our development strategy.
We're learning.
We're a small organization.
Some of my team are absolutely
fantastic at logistics--
and now, increasingly, at
developing markets in Africa.
AUDIENCE: What is the
lifetime for a stove?
FRED COLGAN: Well, when we
started, we weren't sure.
We've had stoves in the
field now for four years,
with almost zero failure rate.
So we're waiting for
that first failure point.
We think somewhere in
year five, year six,
we're going to see some
deterioration of some
of the parts.
But these are
interchangeable parts.
So with maintenance, we're
confident a ten-year lifespan
is possible, and maybe longer.
The only stoves that have failed
have been left out in the rain.
So we're looking at a
very, very long livelihood
for these stoves.
I want to thank you for coming.
And I want to thank you, Dan,
for hosting us, and making
this possible.
DAN: Thank you for
coming, Fred and Assitan.
FRED COLGAN: Thanks.
And please don't
hesitate to contact us.
And please, spread
the word about us.
We only survive by
the partnerships
and the collaborations
that we make.
Thank you very much.
ASSITAN SYLLA TRAORE:
Thank you for coming.
[APPLAUSE]